All right,
we're going to play a video real quick
and then a liquid and I are going to talk
about it.
Sounds good.
Let me find it.
I'm already failing here.
Alright,
well you know when you also have
to look with regards to that.
The shadow ideas like you have
to get in touch with your anger.
You know,
lots of people are resentful
about all sorts of things.
They're resentful about,
oh
women and they're resentful about men and
they're resentful about the patriarchy
and they're resentful about the left wing,
resentful about the right wing and the
resentful about politicians and they're
resentful about the cataclysmic force
of nature and its ability to make people
sick and and suffer and they're resentful
about their own inadequacies in the
boat.
Their bad parenting and God like the
list is just bloody endless and that can
make you very,
very angry and that's part of that
resentment and cynical and bitter and dark
and full of fantasies about destruction
and the desire to bring things down and
the wish that everyone else suffered and
the desire to shake your fist at God.
And all of that's really dark.
You know,
young said,
well,
the shadow human shadow extends
all the way down to hell.
Okay,
we're going to try that one more
time because I failed there.
Uh,
let's try this again.
I touch with the depths of your anger.
You know,
lots of people are resentful
about all sorts of things.
They're resentful about,
oh,
women.
And they're resentful about men and their
research and they're resentful of the
left.
Wait 26,
present politicians and
resentful about the,
like the cataclysmic force of nature
and its ability to make people sick and
suffer and they're
resentful about their own.
And now he's in the boat.
They're bad parents suffer
both nature and stuff.
And it's true.
A lot of people
say that say the systems that we live
in are what causes our suffering,
and that's true.
It can add to the suffering,
but ultimately the suffering
is just being itself,
you know,
and.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
And you know,
the,
the very idea of resentment.
I've just come across a paper
or a book called on resentment.
I'm forgetting who the
authors are and it's a
constantly.
It goes over different people including
a nature and Virginia Woolf on and finch
who was a 17th century poet,
I think,
you know,
she was a very much against the Patriarchy
and Virginia Woolf basically spells
out that it was a and finches,
you know,
dwelling in her own writing
that contributed to her
a resentment and that the
very act of writing for her was,
you know,
the,
uh,
the source of her own mental illness.
And it's constantly,
it,
you constantly see that these authors
or writers mentioned resentment as a
mental illness.
And I never,
I mean,
I've heard Peterson talk about it and
he may have even explicitly said that,
but,
you know,
never have.
I,
uh,
you know,
never outside of him have I thought about
it like that or heard it from somebody
else.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
Okay.
I've listened to a lot of his Bible
lectures and when the store is the way he
describes the enable story,
it really made me think about like in my
own life when I've thought about house,
maybe I blame someone else for
my problems or how I blamed,
like,
you know,
the fact of being then I thought about
and that makes sense because like,
what am I actually blaming,
not blaming the fact that I'm just
alive and if I'm blaming that,
then uh,
maybe I should do something to make
that better rather than just blaming
everyone else.
Um,
yeah,
it certainly has.
I think it happens to everybody.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
if,
I,
I guess everybody can be a victim,
but I think what's another
interesting thing in that book it,
I forget the author who,
I think it might've been a
character guard that said,
I'm not sure that might
be another person that,
you know,
you need a victim,
you need a victimizer,
but then you also need this,
you know,
this third person,
this spectator who basically
is emancipated from the
resentment or resentment or
sorry,
emancipated from the victimization,
who is able to see it and you know,
almost empathize with the
people who are being victimized.
And Peterson talks about that too,
not necessarily in this video,
but he talks about how,
you know,
it's,
it can be evil to,
um,
to empathize with somebody else's problems
and
you're robbing them of their
own capacity to solve them.
Right?
They like taking on their problems,
stealing.
Then yeah,
I listened to a,
uh,
Steven Hicks called a post explaining
postmodernism and kierkegaard comes up
quite a bit,
but,
uh,
anyway,
so I guess maybe we should get back to
the video and see what comes up next.
All right.
So I'm at 39 seconds.
Okay,
let me,
I'm at 49 and I'll come back to the.
I'll come back to 39.
Okay.
Likelihood you have of terrible capacity
for destructive testing in the boat.
They're bad.
God like the list is just bloody endless.
And that can make you very,
very angry that that's part
of that resentment at 54 dark.
And one thing you mentioned is a two says
the list is almost endless and that's
sort of goes along the lines of it reaches
to the deepest depths of hell if you
really follow that,
uh,
that list,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
you can always think of a
worse place you could be in.
You could always think of a
worse thing that you could do.
I mean,
yeah,
it's absolutely endless.
I mean,
you,
you hear about,
you know,
atrocities in the world and though
some stand out more than others.
Um,
and you know,
dare I say know genocide of
6 million plus you had
the concentration camps.
Then you also had the in the,
uh,
oh yeah.
Your blood left in eastern
Europe as they move towards
Russia.
Um,
but you know,
it
can always be worse.
I mean,
here's a visual for you.
So there's a train that night train that
goes from Moscow to St Petersburg and
uh,
I took that terrain and the entire,
almost the entire length of
the railway is just grades
and it's quite the distance.
It takes a eight to nine hours
or so to the trainer there.
So
yeah,
that's it.
You can see them in the moonlight.
You could,
you just like the
reflections of the crosses.
It's millions or hundreds.
At least hundreds of thousands.
I could see like the one that
train track it was crazy.
Yeah,
like things,
things going to be way more,
way worse than then you
could even imagine that.
Yeah.
I can't even comprehend that now.
I mean,
seeing that would just probably
leave me numb for a little while.
You know,
it was hard to really
contemplate when I was only 17,
but I still kind of remember it.
Um,
the,
it was not,
never seen anything like that before.
It reminded me of my
grandparents when they went to a,
their insurance stationed in
Germany after the war and uh,
they would go to the Canadian,
an ally,
a grave sites and it just the miles
and miles of a cross as well and looked
some,
I guess Jewish graves
in some Muslim grades,
but mostly mostly,
uh,
crosses.
But I remember my grandma,
my mom remembers my grandma just
crying and crying and crying.
Yeah.
Because these are all men
that she might've known,
right?
Yeah.
No.
Oh.
Anyways,
so we're,
I'm at 54 seconds.
I'll,
uh,
I'll start.
You can go ahead,
start.
Maybe we'll stop at like why
you choose the next stop.
Alright.
Just tell me a desire
to bring things down.
Wished that everyone else suffered and
desire to shake your fist at God and all
of that really dark.
You know,
Young said,
well the shadow human shout,
it extends all the way down to
help and he really meant that,
you know,
because all the terrible things that
people are motivated to do are associated
with that shadow domain.
And like none of you are any.
None of you are saints in any likelihood.
You have a terrible capacity
for destructiveness and
when you start to consult
your resentment and to
see how angry you are,
it can terrify you or deceive the depths
of that anger sometimes will manifest
itself in very good.
Alright,
so I stopped at.
Yeah,
I wonder sometimes what it would be like
four,
some of the,
uh,
people who
err on the side of social
justice to actually see what,
what the possibilities
of their own thinking,
what the fruit of their
theories.
But if you were to play out their own
narrative,
yeah,
if you were to play out
their own narrative,
what that would lead to and you know,
it's probably inevitably
leads to the same,
you know,
if it's,
if it's fueled by resentment,
probably if it fuels and is always
fed with the same resentment,
then it will inevitably lead to murder.
I mean that's,
well most utopic vision.
The problem with them is that
they can never really be achieved.
I guess good to have some goals,
like reduce suffering.
That's not a bad goal,
but if your idea's elimination
of suffering at all.
Oh,
oh,
more suffering than it's ever been seen.
And history,
at least in the 20th century,
uh,
has shown us showing us that that's,
that's,
that's history that we know this
history in the past that's just as bad.
It's all for offer utopia.
Yeah.
You can never really achieve it.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah,
you can't,
you can't eliminate suffering.
But,
uh,
another interesting,
another interesting
idea in that book on resentment,
I'll throw it into the description though,
you know,
it's an 50 to $80 ebook
is,
and I forget who says this.
It's,
you know,
it's a thinker that most
other people would know,
but they mentioned that it's a,
that it's in an impotent lust for revenge.
You know,
it's almost like the person
knows that they're vulnerable.
Victim knows that they're vulnerable,
but that they can't do anything.
And so their resentment is
fueled by their own impotency.
I mean,
it's almost like this,
uh,
the more whether or not they're,
they feel sorry whether or
not a person is wronged.
Like if a person continues to,
to,
uh,
to think
about being victimized,
then you know,
they,
they just keep fueling the
resentment and it's an,
it's easy.
It's,
you know,
it can easily happen,
especially if you start to,
you know,
like Peterson says you,
I don't know if he says this,
but you know,
if you keep feeding the dragon,
you know,
it just keeps getting bigger and
bigger and just ignore it too.
Yeah.
And if you ignore it,
but,
you know,
even if you,
if you can stop for a little while
and then continue again later,
you know,
it's,
it made the dragon may have
gotten smaller but you know,
it's still a drag and then it
hasn't completely disappeared yet.
Anything you ignore a will get bigger
in the background and we'll start taking
up more and more of your,
uh,
your thoughts because you're
not dealing with the problem.
Yeah.
But also,
but also if you feed it,
that's also gonna cause problems
as well because you know,
if you're adding to it,
you're adding to the problem
rather than confronting.
It was really a,
when you confront resentment,
you're really just confronting yourself
and a lot of people don't have the
courage to do that and fair enough,
this,
that's a tough one to do,
but if you want to get better,
you've got to do it.
Yeah.
Because,
you know,
your resentment is,
is personal.
It's all the ways in which,
unless it's,
you know,
in fueled by ideology.
And then it may be that,
you know,
the idea that there is an idea that's
controlling you rather than you.
I'm expounding an idea,
but let's say that the resentment is
personal and there's not an idealogue
driving it.
Um,
then you really have to,
you know,
get a,
hold on it,
get a hold of it and
figure out what exactly.
Well,
yeah,
it seems like Peterson says like the
socialists and if he got that from Orwell,
uh,
the Socialists don't love the poor,
they just hate the rich.
And the strange thing with
that is that they actually,
they hate the rich,
but the ideal idealize Islam,
and that's why they hate them because
they're resentful of the fact that they're
not rich or you know,
there's some sort of moral
quandary with having wealth,
which really there isn't.
The problem is they don't have it.
So they wanted to destroy
it and that's like the,
you know,
the typical out difficult.
But the Cain and Abel story is all,
is that,
that's what that can enable story is it's
someone who idealized is something and
then tries to destroy it in
order to make themselves better.
But what happens when you destroy it,
you realize that you've
just destroyed your ideal,
which in a sense you've
destroyed yourself.
Where your soul is.
The Christians would say,
yeah,
let's just,
you know,
I'm going to continue on.
Yeah,
I'm at the [inaudible] 37.
me too.
Okay.
Fit.
Just fantasies.
You know,
which you might not want to become
conscious of because they're so brutal,
let's say.
And so aggressive that you can't even
believe that you generate them the nice
person.
That's you.
It's like,
so it's quite frightening to open that
door and see all that and that also
associates you with the
entire dark shadow of mankind,
right?
The tannic element of
the human character and,
but it opens the door to
understanding as well to,
to understanding how people can do
terrible things because you could see
yourself as one of the people
who could be positive things.
That's through twelfth.
So when he says people
like they're on aisle,
I've found a lot of people are like,
if you ask them a question that if
they're capable of doing a terrible thing,
they'll usually say no,
right?
Because there's not a monster,
but that's the problem.
Because if they're a human being and
other human beings are capable of doing
that terrible thing,
then automatically you're capable
of doing that terrible thing too,
right?
The only thing that's
stopping you is something,
right?
So is it because you're a coward?
Which is what Nietzsche would say,
um,
or is it because the laws or is it
because you have a reason not to do it?
And if you asked where the
resentment thing comes in,
because maybe your reason is that you,
okay,
you have resentment,
figured you're dealing with it yourself,
like it's your problem and you're
not externalizing it to those things.
And
Yeah,
I,
uh,
I read,
I haven't read police battalion are.
I haven't read ordinary men completely.
In fact,
they haven't even started
reading it yet because I was,
I was seeing little excerpts and one of
the excerpts that stood out to me was
that a police battalion,
I think it was one on one,
was made up of,
I forget who the author.
I'm a classified three
different types of men.
The men who were eager
to kill the men who were,
I'm
a
who would,
who would kill but weren't
initiating the action.
They would have to be initiated against.
They would have to have
someone initiate them to kill,
but they would kill willingly.
Then the men who would basically
try and avoid the killing.
And you know,
obviously,
you know,
all three groups said we're,
well,
we're part of the problem.
Not only part of the problem,
but you know,
I guess I'd have to read it to find
out maybe more about the groups
for sure.
Like I have a lot more reading to do.
I've been doing more and
more reading over time,
but uh,
you know,
there's a lot of stuff to read.
So yeah.
I'm just wondering.
Yeah,
I'm wondering,
you know,
how much some of these individuals
were in touch with their own darkness?
You know,
I,
I would be hard pressed to think that,
you know,
the eager killers were all,
in touch with their own.
Or maybe they would be the ones
in touch with their own darkness,
but they were the ones
who continued to feed it.
Yeah.
That's the other.
Feeding the dragon rather than
integrated into themselves.
Yeah.
If you're,
if you're,
if you're not really using
the tool of consciously,
then then you're,
then you're just feeding the dragon.
If you're.
There's times when you
should be a monster,
but if it's like shooting women in the
back of the head and open and feels like
that's not really a time,
that's obviously,
that's obviously a pathological situation,
but
you've got to control it.
And maybe the men who killed willingly
because they knew that they had to,
whatever that means.
Um,
we,
uh,
were ones who were in touch,
but because they wouldn't
initiate it themselves,
maybe they were ones who,
God,
it's hard to say because,
you know,
Peter.
Yeah.
They were following [inaudible] Peterson,
you know,
obviously mentioned,
when you start to think for yourself that,
you know,
I could be one of the,
you think to yourself that I
can be one of those guards,
w,
what would I have to do to make sure
that that would never happen now will,
I don't know because I
haven't read the book,
but I don't know of any three
of any individual in that
group that chose not to.
Or how about this?
Like what would it take?
What would your life have to be like
in order to make a decision like that?
Like realistically,
yeah,
that's another question should be asked
to because maybe if anybody's capable of
it,
it maybe,
maybe it's good to realize
what you would have to,
what kind of situation you
would have to be in to a reset.
Same sort of decision.
Yeah.
That's necessary to even
begin thinking about it,
you know,
to put yourself in that position,
you have to wonder,
you know,
what,
what situation would I have to be in?
Especially for the people who claim that
they could never be in that position
because they're good people.
You know,
they were good people.
We only killed $100,
million innocent civilians in
the 20th century for ideals,
but it was worth it.
Right.
It's an absolute monsters.
Oh,
I wouldn't.
If I was in charge of the utopia,
it would have been ushered in.
Okay,
well then what happens to people like
you a while you get taken out by the cell
in type system,
what Peterson says anyways.
And that makes sense.
I know.
Yeah.
I'm going to continue to let this go.
I'm at 10 to 12.
Okay.
No,
because then you.
Well then maybe you start to be motivated
to be the sort of person who wouldn't
do terrible things.
You know,
if you can really come to terms with
the fact that that's part and parcel of
you.
It also is some perverse sense.
It's also a discovery of
your own strength though,
because you know if you have
that desire for aggression,
that desire for destruction and that
that ability to fantasize in that
aggressive manner,
it also means that you can incorporate
some of that into your speech and into
your actions so that you're
a lot more immovable,
right,
and and a lot more of a
force to contend with.
It can give you some respect for yourself
when you realize that you're a force
of destruction as well as creation,
and then you're also more likely to treat
yourself with a bit more intelligent.
Caution,
you know,
to know that you're a part of you is a
ticking bomb in some sense that could go
off and so you,
you,
you tried a bit more lightly around
yourself and maybe you encourage people to
tread more lightly around you as well.
Okay,
so I know that's too in my life where,
uh,
if I'm,
if I'm passive,
people sort of tread all over you,
but if you take yourself seriously and
you don't let yourself get pushed around
and people read off that too,
and then they treat you better,
you know,
they treat you seriously.
Yeah.
But I've also found
that,
uh,
sometimes,
in my own experiences through work,
you know,
a lot of times when I
worked in a cabinet shop,
you know,
I'd be somewhat aggressive sometimes
trying to rally people together and some,
you know,
more often than not that aggression,
it could be a better place.
I'm trying to ask somebody for help,
uh,
and people just thinking,
you know,
well,
we don't have to do that or you know,
that's not required to me or
you're not my boss and the,
it would be for the good of the company,
you know.
Well,
that's another thing too,
is like you have to match it with your
perceived competence competency to,
um,
if you've earned sort of the,
uh,
if you've earned your stripes so to speak.
I find that people are way more
willing to take you seriously.
Like I've,
I've worked in two different trades.
I've been a carpenter and I've been
a nominal electric later and uh,
I was a young guy so I had no experience.
I had very little knowledge by just
kind of like did all the hard work and
eventually an ass a lot of questions
and eventually they're like,
okay.
They started taking it more seriously
and I got my apprenticeship and stuff.
And then I met six months later I
moved to a different trade altogether,
but I just kept trying to move up.
But my point is,
is that by getting up,
I actually jumped ahead
of other guys that were,
uh,
also apprentices,
but there were there longer because
my work ethic pushed me into a more
respectable position.
So when I would mention something
they would take it seriously,
which was also helpful.
But I haven't been in the other position
to where I'm trying to bring up ideas
and I have an earned my stripes yet I'm
kind of too incompetent to like make a
change and then people just
ignore you or whatever.
Yeah.
I find it much more tough when you're a,
you know,
you work longer and your competency
level is already fairly high.
But know people aren't necessarily.
Well you might have a high.
But I'm not that I'm talking to myself up,
but,
you know,
I guess there's always
different situations.
Um,
but we'll have,
you know,
what exactly do you think
Peterson means by integrating,
integrating it,
your speech by what you're
saying by basically taking
yourself seriously and not
being passive.
Like what would be an
example you think of?
Like for example,
when I was working in carpentry,
did we ever doing a garage for a,
a big,
a large residential building?
And uh,
I noticed that my cousin was actually
contracted us the person to do the roofing
and stealing and stuff
of all the concrete.
And I noticed that one of the walls on
the parking garage wasn't sealed with
tar.
And I've mentioned that to my,
I was an apprentice,
so I mentioned to my carpenter
a journeyman and he's like,
oh yeah,
that makes sense.
Normally as he called me.
And so I went and got
tempted to talk to her.
He went and went and talked
to the superintendent and
the Superintendent said,
ah,
now we don't need to worry about it.
So then they fill it in,
right?
Because they're almost like the space.
And I fill that in with backfill and down
over the weekend it and all the water.
Although water from the rain soaked
through the concrete and was like,
that's a huge problem,
right?
Yeah.
So they had to take it all out
and then we seal the whole thing,
which would have been solved
already if they listened to me,
but they didn't listen to me because
I was just a dumb apprentice by this.
Noted that there was a problem and I had,
I thought of a solution.
So I presented it and my journeymen
thought it was a good idea.
So he passed it on and then
they didn't take it seriously,
but then they had to fix it anyways.
So it cost them lots of money.
Maybe that.
Yeah.
But because I did something like that,
they,
they'd take me.
It started taking more seriously.
Um,
fair enough.
Right.
You don't want like there's a bunch of
young idiots out there that think they
know everything,
which is like the first
day when you think the.
So they say the Delphi of the Oracle of
Delphi said that socrates was the wisest
of the Greeks because he
alone movie knew nothing.
And uh,
this true,
the more you know,
you don't know.
So this sort of a good
thing to keep in mind.
You gotta know if you're competent
before you try to make change,
which a lot of people are like,
Eh,
I don't need to do that.
So they just go out and run around like
a bull in a China shop and no one takes
them seriously because why would you?
Right.
Yeah.
That makes a lot of sense.
I think that's what Peterson means with a.
When he says like,
make you clean your room,
it's a prove to yourself that you have
competency to do so because if you can't
do that,
then maybe you should reassess your own
competency and it's people make fun of
it because it's like silly,
right?
But the point is is you're supposed to
test your competency competency or making
a room and then you test your
competency and other things.
Maybe keeping your house clean and uh,
and then try to realize that if
you know that you're competent,
then you have the confidence in your
speech and the precision of your speech to
make a bigger suggestions more,
more,
more worldly inside your family or
inside your friend circle or your work
outside of your own personal life.
Maybe then you could have some confidence
in your competency because otherwise,
what are you,
right?
You're just,
you could just be any
random joe with that ideas.
And are they supposed to
take everyone seriously?
It was too many people know to do that.
Yeah.
So that's why you're saying it's important
to prove to yourself that you have
competency.
That's what the whole
cleaning room thing is
least in my opinion.
Yeah.
He tied it together nicely.
All right.
Well,
do you want to keep going?
We got it.
Yeah.
Okay.
I got a three.
18 almost started up.
Okay,
well did.
I really admired that.
I know have a clearly dangerous
side and you don't want to get,
you don't want to have that
activated any more than necessary,
but it's also what makes
them respectable and strong,
especially if they have
that under control.
So.
Oh,
that's a bit of a dialogue
about shadow integration.
It's a very
challenging undertaking,
you know,
to pull in that dark side of your
character and that would be all the things
that you've repressed or failed to
develop as a consequence of trying to be a
harmless and uh,
well let's say harmless,
harmless citizen who looks
virtuous on the surface.
That's the union persona.
And you need that because everybody
needs a mask that they wear in public,
like a suit,
you know,
so that we can tolerate seeing
each other on the street.
We don't have to look right
into our depths every time
we interact you need that
persona,
but now it has to be transcendent.
And the way to transcend
that is to integrate.
The darker parts of the
character are very useful demand.
For example,
I've noticed that if you see
like sjws how they dress,
they always stressed with like,
you know,
kind of unconventionally
a lot of the time.
Not all of them do,
but sort of the crazy
ones do I haven't seen,
you know,
other than some of the protests
that Peterson has been at.
Yeah,
I know.
I kind of know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
Yes.
So that,
that's sort of like the reason why they
do that is because they're trying to be
unconventional,
but the result and uh,
the results and feelings from a,
I guess people that are conventional as
they see sort of see sort of the chaos
in their own minds being expressed.
Right?
So they show themselves as incompetent
and then they show themselves further and
competent in the way they speak.
So when they cry and like that,
there's like those memes of people crying
when trump was elected or sworn in or
whatever.
Um,
and it just,
like these people are showing,
their masks are falling off essentially,
and it's important to have those masks,
like when,
if you're coming,
if you come across someone that's like
dressed shabbily and they smell and uh,
they're not,
they're sort of,
I guess you could say unconventional,
but really they just have poor hygiene.
Your art kind of put off,
right?
You don't watch it.
They might interact with light,
but you're going to try to avoid them.
Right.
And uh,
yeah.
So yeah,
I,
I wonder,
um,
yeah,
I think I'll start looking for that more.
I definitely can say I have seen that in
some of the people that stick out in my
head and some of the videos,
yeah,
like if you've come across sort of like
a homeless guy and if you stare at him,
like he might start freaking out at you,
right?
Because you're,
you're seeing him for what as he is and
he's probably a little bit embarrassed
by that.
So he might come at you or he might yell
at you or he show his chaos and which
stocks because you don't want
to treat people like that,
but that's just the way
things are sometimes.
So,
uh,
it's important if you want to see
another important side of this competency
thing is you got to appear competent
because people might not know and if you
show that you can appear competent,
then people are more likely to want to
interact with you because they're going
to see you.
Uh,
that's a more peaceful person I guess
in some way because they're going to be
able to know that,
okay,
well,
if a person's able to take care
of themselves hygienically,
then you know,
maybe I can have an actual conversation
with this person compared to a guy going
to be covered in actual garbage.
Then this can be difficult,
right?
Because you're going to
be constantly smelling or,
or whatever.
Yeah.
I
don't know how much it's
hearsay or where it came from,
but I heard that Marx was a.
was it pretty dirty,
dirty person?
Smelled,
or we call them,
we call them,
I call them dirty Santa Claus.
Man filled with resentment is so,
so resentful that he almost started
his own children who really.
Yeah.
Well it doesn't even have a job.
So he wasn't really
keeping up with the Miller,
isn't he really is the only,
only reason he was able to like
get by lists because angles,
who was a son of a rich industrialists
was sending him money basically
and uh,
to help him with his writings.
I suppose that's,
that's the only reason why otherwise
I think he had like four or five kids.
Don't quote me on that,
but yeah.
Yeah.
Didn't you horror on his own wife to A.
I don't know.
I can't say if that's true or not.
But yeah,
I mean,
well,
okay.
Don't want to pick on somebody that
can't defend themselves anymore.
I want to start again at 4:32.
Only a little bit left.
So.
Okay,
I'll start up.
That's very difficult to
socialize that competitiveness,
but unbelievably useful in terms of force
and the character if you could manage
it.
Yeah.
I think a sane socialized,
socializing the competitiveness,
that's has a lot to do with what you
were talking about with competency and
um,
no,
if you are competitive,
you know,
a great thing to do is first to
appear competent so that you can
display your competitiveness with some.
Perfect.
I don't know what I'm saying.
Well,
when I was,
when I was younger,
I used to think I was really,
really competent.
Like I,
I thought I knew everything right.
Which you don't really understand like
when you're 18 and you think you know
everything,
you don't realize how
little you actually know.
Right.
So what I was,
what I would I changed over time was
I just started reading more and then I
started realizing I'm like,
Oh shit,
I almost,
I know almost nothing
about the more I've read,
um,
the more I realized that,
but there's like 17,
18,
19 year old kid,
sometimes 20 year olds that are out there
protesting and they don't really know
what the hell they're protesting.
Like you can even see it in
even Peterson and his history.
He's been in this situation where he was,
he ran for healing,
he was like 16 or something.
I ran for the vice president of the,
a new Democratic Party in Alberta,
which is the Socialist Party,
sort of democratic
socialist party in Canada.
And I was also a member of that party
and I used to like do campaigning for a
couple of the people that are eventually
won seats and I was like a campaign
called captain or whatever
have a section of the,
of the city.
And uh,
I mean it was fine.
It was interesting experience,
but now I look back on it.
There was a lot of Weirdos in that,
in that grouping.
Like there's a lot of people
that they weren't very competent,
but they thought they knew everything.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's the dangerous combination.
I'm actually remembering a couple of
times in my own hometown where I had seen
a,
a random group that had popped up,
but Lyndon Larouche group,
which was like a halfway between
a conspiracy theory group.
And
I don't know,
I don't know exactly
how to more like a cult.
A cult would be a good,
a good way to define them,
but I remember a lot of the people
and I know I'm harping on it again,
but we're dressed up
and dressed really odd.
Yeah.
And a lot of them were,
you know,
as old as me and it was just a,
I had approached the table because they
were just at the local post office and I
was there for something and
I'm thinking to myself like,
these guys are a little bit weird.
So I grabbed the brochure and
started looking at it and you know,
so you know,
some of the literature sound good?
Yeah.
It seems interesting on the surface,
but you know,
just judging by the people
who are already there,
it's like I don't think I want to
get involved with these people.
It's kind of funny how that's
kind of habits unconscious.
Something you picked up unconsciously.
It might.
Yeah,
it,
it's,
it's funny because it stares
you right in the face,
but it's still sort of unconscious
because you give them this era of respect
that they may not deserve a
automatically because you know,
that's a way to have a peaceful society,
but unconsciously maybe
subconsciously or unconsciously you,
you see the,
you know,
something's up with them.
Yeah.
Subconsciously I think it was
the word I was looking for.
I'm not sure what the
proper terminology is.
That as again,
I'm not educated.
I just read a lot.
Um,
but yeah,
it's interesting you see it with a
scientology people too sometimes,
like,
still crazy.
Yeah.
I've never,
I've never come across
anybody in scientology.
They have a chapter in Vancouver,
in the poor area,
like we're a lot of the homeless people
live now and I don't know exactly how
they,
maybe they survived because
almost pick of the money,
which I think could be kind
of a bad marketing plan.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
they're right in the middle
of the downtown east side,
like right beside the unit.
Do you ever heard of Mark Emery?
The principal?
No.
Okay.
Well,
he has a store downtown or he did back
in the day called cannabis culture or
something and it was like right
beside the scientology office,
which I thought was
funny because Mark Emery,
he's the kind of guy that would get,
you would expect him to make
sort of like a pot centric,
a religion.
Uh,
ironically,
but,
uh,
he wouldn't have that.
He would never join scientology,
but I wonder if maybe I'm scientology
put themselves there on purpose or,
or maybe it was just you
happened to be there.
Well,
they do a,
they do kind of prey on the abused.
The addicted.
Yeah.
The vulnerable people vulnerable.
That's a better way to.
Yeah,
that's a better word I'm
looking for and you know,
that,
you know,
it's scary because in 2005 or six,
they were actually one of the will self.
They claimed it themselves,
but they were one of the fastest
growing religions in the world.
Uh,
I think they were publishing and oh man,
I don't know how many different languages,
which is scary.
Yeah.
Well,
like,
who?
The Mormons are passing them.
Not that I'm really a
fan of more medicine,
but it's definitely better than.
Yeah,
yeah.
At least.
Or an old drug addicted.
They dress well and don't smell.
So that's what wasn't good for wives,
you know,
I'm just,
there's nothing wrong with that.
I would not lie for us.
Way Too much.
One's enough.
Exactly.
But uh,
yeah.
Well,
so what do you,
what do you think seems pretty.
Well,
I think,
uh,
yeah.
Maybe we will just cut it here and
we'll come back later and above.
All right.
Take care of
it.
Do.